das österreichische bundesheer hat
insgesamt 18 arbeits und transporte mit
einem gesamtvolumen von 4 8 millionen
euro beschafft produziert wurden sie bei
der firma s werft linz ag die sich im
wettbewerb zwischen fünf bietern
durchgesetzt hat die boote sind 85 meter
lang und 25 meter breit haben einen
tiefgang von einem halben meter und ein
eigengewicht von 2,5 tonnen
die zweiköpfige besatzung erreicht mit
dem 260 ps starken dieselmotor eine
geschwindigkeit von rund 70
stundenkilometern
neben einem breitband radar gps und
echolot zur orientierung steht eine
keppler bugklappe zur raschen be und
entladung zur verfügung
die boote sind für den mannschafts und
geräte transport unter anderem bei
katastropheneinsätzen sowie als
schwimmende arbeitsplattform vorgesehen
die board bestattung ein fahrer in
bodman können zwölf personen mit gerät
ausrüstung transportieren oder im
gesamtvolumen 1800 kilogramm
die drei pioniere bataillone des
bundesheeres in villach salzburg wurden
mit je drei stück ausgestattet die es
drucken schule erhielt neun boote für
ihre aufgaben